I'm here with three other gamers he
played the anthem demo I've never met
that before but we have to play together
as a team
if you don't rely on your team you will
probably fail at the game
watch me do that this could be fun I am
very excited to see how this turns out
this is going to be interesting I want
to jump into the game
so we've got England we've got France
we've got Germany and we've got the USA
this is a really weird mix to bring
together girl we're gonna play some VIP
and some demo and you know anthems a
game all about teaming up so I say let's
team up this work you guys favorite I've
played I never played but you're the
only one who hasn't played yes okay so
this is your seat here alright I'm
hitting team leader on this okay thank
you let's see if we can figure out how
to work together this is be an
experiment I'm ready yeah ready more
than ever you're the boss
alright let's hop in let's jump into the
forge cuz I kind of want to change up
how I'm looking so this is this is the
den when we start out as just Rangers
right yeah yeah this is the VIP demo and
what we're selling out is the sort of
the first javelin I guess so we can kind
of get to grips with everything
shall we should we just do like primary
colors in green or what it really simple
are we getting crazy
deeps bleep max is doing I'm red yeah
feel like a nice Christmas theme and
check this out um there's a lot of a lot
of customization there is a serious
amount of customization I think you can
pick some real custom colors as well so
there's a lot of really really good
presets it sounds like you're planning
something I know exactly what I'm going
for but I might say that for later okay
now I'm gonna just go like a little sort
of first foray into this to keep it nice
and clean okay red
yes okay red I'm looking over I want to
make sure I'm not copying and that's
your thankful wild yeah or maybe I'm
going too much you're going for that
kind of like I walked into like a paint
factory and knocked everything over look
I am so excited to see what people do
with this like I know there's gonna be
like screenshots of just I don't know
maybe javelins that look like familiar
properties and things one last week and
I think I've got my guy ready yeah I'm
just just to make sure you have to give
me at least two hours of genius you look
like a gaming PC yeah
you see on legs man oh animation Oh
victory animation okay III wouldn't
bother changing okay just the paint I'm
ready I think we all start with coming
here you don't need that uh animation
you'll be fine I think we'll be spamming
the ones we have no matter what we do so
um let me take a look and see what you
what you can feel and I want to make
sure I'm not too similar to you well I
don't think is any risk with max I would
really like to apologize right now to
the team at Bioware that spent all this
time making this game and designing it
and then letting me in here max I'm
particularly drawn to the cheeks on the
back of your Evelyn man yeah let's go
real it's a real bright green there I
like this a very green piece look at
this so I don't get hit in traffic when
I'm out you know fighting monsters hello
how are you doing it's it's a simpler
one it's a bit of a blue sky oh yeah and
also sort of devilish red blue blue sky
to go with your blue sky attitude yeah
blue sky so what's yours look like uh so
I've gone for a kind of like a blue
silvery thing a kind of my take on a
wintery that's certainly tame yeah I'm
like a it's like a business casual job
I'm going I say that's it I'm I'm trying
to go understated so that maybe later
down the line I can I could go a bit
more experimental it's like the Java
need to go to work on a word you got to
work with on Mondays yeah exactly
I don't know they they want to break any
horror in this early week your dev looks
a bit like like mine I think you should
change should we suit up
sure we are yeah I love this animation
so much yeah like this was this was in
that like III reveal that they did and I
was like I think is that gonna is that
gonna be in the in the game is that
gonna happen I'm so glad it is yeah yeah
I think you know what it feels like it
feels kind of claustrophobic as you jump
in which I really like you know the
feeling of like I I am really part of
this javelin okay so I think the first
thing we're going to do is we need to
actually go and have a little explore
around for Tarsus and go find out what
our first story mission is wait so we
can't fly the javelins yet we need to go
let's
go join the story Triple Threat yeah so
I'm getting ahead of myself I just
really really want to get in the suit
that's that's totally like one of those
like adventure things like well first
we're gonna go safety precautions you
really I know you want to ride there
when we can just stay yeah
don't you boys want to ride the dune
buggies but first you got to learn about
helmets nice all right so this is this
is for Tarsus this is the this is the
hub and where basically you're going to
start off in the VIP demo if you're
playing it's nice
it looks like a neighborhood I know it
is it's just like walking around Paris
looks like pose yeah Tarsus is much
bigger than I realized as well I'm
already lost I love this this like
mysterious machine here I don't know
what this does I think it's a book a
book making machine the book making
machine yeah it's like a really fancy
copier dude he's like I can't make any
more books these cartridges are too
expensive
you'll love it okay it's called the
manifold well technically I call it the
manifold and it does what exactly for
years I had heard of a type of shaper
relic that was able to amplify and
augment the qualities of other objects
and you think it'll amplify and augment
the power of my javelin precisely I've
sent all the particulars of the location
to faith I can't wait I'm unclear is he
cold or hot cuz he has no sleeves but a
scarf on that's a good look say let's go
to the jelly shall we synchronize I say
on the on the counter go say three deep
is it three two one we go or three two
we go three two we go three two one go
and go okay okay all right three two one
in yes yeah perfect I love that I feel
so cool right now feels yeah I like to
think this is what you know like real
like military outfitting people do you
know when
about together like three to one revolt
synchronize and one guy say okay so we
are going to be doing the triple threat
some matheus has sent us to look for a
relic so that we can build a really
powerful javelin of dawn should we
switch difficulty alright it's on easy I
think we should leave it like this no I
don't know yeah yeah easy easy
okay yeah let's warm up on the game then
we could switch on medium and let's
let's not pretend that we are doing this
for any other reason than you genius
okay
just nice and easy be okay alright I've
readied up I'm good to go just to make
sure if there is any kind of stealth
mission yeah next is our guy okay yeah
you're a you're a scout ahead are you
guys afraid I'm free I'm excited I'm
excited we're gonna use teamwork to take
care of each other yeah very good been
waiting this for a long time yeah we'll
carry by that what we mean is we'll send
you in first yeah yeah the biggest boost
in experience like zoomin shield yeah
what's the French for bullet sponge take
my take my flares suffer God you look
like Shrek it's disturbing I think
that's giving me too much credit well I
change colors impellers a bit but it's a
chance you are you are the correct
colour for me at least so romantic
they're going to see you looking as you
wish to be alright so we've we've
arrived here we're ready to set off and
we need to find a manifold for Matias
and the manifold is the relic that's
gonna help us build this javelin dawn so
if we look at the distance or the
direction we want to head off in we've
got a marker over there and it's not a
race but if it were I'd be
[Music]
new it's coming flying is so nice I
really like that moment where you you
know where you set off and you just get
that real like thump in the back like
yeah that feels good yeah okay
guys don't leave me guys don't leave me
guys look at ya there's bunnies down
here it's birds birds guys I told you
I'm coming back I'm coming back oh maybe
I overheated and I'm also being shot at
you're shooting you okay this is off to
a bad start
yeah no story max remember that whole
teamwork thing we were gonna forget
about everything just shootin one I
really want to happy but I try to
harvest my naruse it's okay it's okay I
got this I got this guy
so we'll just defend Florian while he'll
eats this place for all these lefty
harvest why is everything on fire what
did you guys do are we eating the birds
they yeah they attacked me it's not my
fault
just like regular earth birds they do
tend to burst into flames when attacks
it's very realistic
it's an homage in the various way oh so
much much bigger enemies down here as
well what okay where are we team are we
all together we made okay
I see max I'm gonna floor in ICU genius
all right we're all together I feel like
we should probably these guys alone
absolutely not
yeah what kind of scheme would we be
let's shoot him missile I will have
Selenia let's accept cowardice on this
team yeah what are we supposed to do out
here again
what would a treasure hunt be if we
didn't have to murder a couple of you
know like what are they 4 legged six
legged I'm gonna go put a four leg yeah
close combat shows combat look I'll read
it okay sorry
genius I'm really I'm digging this
bravery or newbie you're you're getting
stuck in thank you like this welcome to
the team animals so where were these
bunnies they they sound like the most
deadly of apres no they're really
they're just kind of weird-looking so it
looks like we've got a new map marker
that's over here and you can boost
sprint now wait wait wait look at this
the bunnies
where are they where are they over here
there in the lake they are terrified of
me now look at them they're like
mothballs yeah do they look dangerous
killable I don't think I just
disintegrated wanna wait alright so
maybe we should get a quest okay let's
go to arrow all right so I think we're
heading down this tunnel so let me check
there's no friendly fire yeah can we
turn it on no way yes you see me okay
okay let's go feels super satisfying and
kind of makes me really wish I had some
kind of like you know XO seat for
sprinting to and from work real urgent
bathroom breaks and you can do a barrel
roll so oh and that it's the most
important thing
let's hop up here so we've got a little
green icon appearing so we need to
follow that you mean max I'm kind of a
green icon like he's a living icon max
you've always been an icon to me you're
so sweet green or otherwise get a room
guys I like how we got this like
terrible buddy cop thing going on you
look like the the straight-laced one and
I'm like I'm here to party
oh yeah you've got a different
personality the strange box did you pick
it up just okay so I think we can prove
it progress through now okay it was
opened up I see a series of red dots
over here which I think means we've got
some friends new friends yeah red
usually means not your enemy
yeah exactly that's probably those
bunnies I bet they're mad at us they've
got they've got a lot of bunny pals
coming in to help
oh my ultimate look at this guy look at
this look at this ah dogs
Oh what human people as well that's
Carey does anyone so I've got my
ultimate charged up already can you use
it you should save it
something really non-threatening there's
a super cool move it could jump in you
press Y you can like oh it's good you
said it yeah jump in first white super
didn't know well I am gonna be easing
that all the time
it's pretty cool okay so let's see if we
can find maybe a okay oh oh so we found
some intelligence which I think it's
gonna hopefully give us our next marker
oh god there's big bugs over here
why I'm gonna prison what yeah you guys
are scooping up all the kills I've got
this horrible feeling I'm gonna end up
with a really really bad rating at the
end of this yeah well you should start
pulling your weight dude I'm trying wait
for me yeah all right I'm using the it's
all melee from here on the mellah is so
fun what was that that was my ultimate
that was pretty cool it was pretty cool
oh I think I've my funny boys wait for
me little dogs over here yeah they're
looking sweet guys already got can i
form you I'm in front of strange that
looks scary yeah they're no bunnies oh
they're nobodies I'm gonna wait guys
just leave no man behind
yeah oh these guys might not be too
strong for us oh no work we're we're
good we're fine we're okay I got my oats
also oops we had yeah we guys we're
invincible so far what we brought to
this planet is nothing but absolute
destruction yeah I don't really I don't
really feel that bad for humanity here
because we're just like yeah kill it all
guys wait we don't have a name for us
quite that is a really good point I feel
like maybe maybe the testing of our
abilities on this this first quest might
determine good name oh we've actually
got our first like slightly harder cross
ah well that was a combo do we have
different of ultras no I think at the
beginning we've got Bulls any same one
yeah for the same guy but that's
definitely to change Oh this dinosaur is
over here there for me
what just to a grenade well like all
right what are we supposed to be doing
again we are recover Cygnus so we're
gonna recover cygnets to access the
Dominion lock breaker so I think we're
taking out the Dominion which are these
well they're the humanoid guys we've
seen hanging out here all right surskit
keep up with max yeah okay so we got a
bit of trick well there's a lot of these
endangered species around oh no not
anymore
they were endangered or although they
weren't in de sorry it's probably for
the best that there's no friendly fire
cuz I would be I think we'd all be dead
we'd all have to killing each other some
some new fauna here that we can kill
look so friendly very full didn't sign
up for this guy that's what they want
you to think okay because we go in
totally the wrong way outside mission
boundaries oh yeah I have to go back I
think we left the mission area we're at
the wrong way all right
transports me back right now oh you guys
getting I was right with you it's just
gonna transport you to right where I am
are you still loading in I'm taking on
this fight by myself let's get in a
reasonable restricted area
you're the leader yeah I think save you
the leader to the rest of us sir
basically this couple heads join you
later
I got this just I'll draw all that fire
we're coming over coming we're coming so
how you holding up is it okay instead
sorry that's all right I'm some
still alive yeah there's one turret down
there we go
say okay well done we're back in Paris I
feel like maybe we should prioritize the
towers yeah there we go okay once almost
okay yeah just try last one I'm trying
to save up an old goes combat all right
all time good there we go nice one oh I
felt really good oh yeah when you can -
and that's cross Oh nicely done what was
that Oh liquid there are more coming
dude okay there guys I'm gonna say that
that was that was reasonably well teamed
as a first team effort a lot of these
guys oh yeah still coming
okay so the lesson I've just learned
here is don't stand in the spawn point
all the bad guys I need I'm gonna bad
shape
that's okay it's a high level dog here
is it okay genius okay thank you for
that oh there's huge dinosaurs max aya
it's a echo you I'm really glad that
there isn't friendly fire cuz my first
really really big attack there just went
straight on your back we're a mess yeah
yeah ultimate that is a real firework
show like yeah am I gonna break into a
lockbox we walk like 10 feet and we're
like ah dinosaurs yeah breaking into a
lockbox is anything like it is killing
animals on this planet we are gonna be
straight into it we'll be fine yeah okay
okay it's behind us yeah that's follow
the leader
well let me get in front then okay so
let's find this box I think it's in this
area gonna cave a little cave yeah yeah
I think is this way wow that's a turret
something so hissing heat I got it it's
not a bunny I repeat it's not a one of
those mechanical danger bunnies milk
stream
okay all right now we're getting a
little sort of scavenger hunt yeah got
it
Oh got it nice and icy done last week
should we do the you do it so we do a
check every time to do something good
yeah okay check the first one I'm not
sure we entirely deserve that can't
interrupt you but some guys shooting at
us oh damn oh yes that's cool that's the
kind of situational awareness this can
get you provided thank you yeah it's
terrifying
oh wait
Oh
yeah oh I've been forgetting tease my
MLA I'm all electrified at the marriage
crazy oh okay oh did you drop your alter
right as we got everyone down exactly
all right now I'm gonna do it yeah
enemies enemies weak difficult now we've
got this got it at least we're all
grouped together so we're giving them a
nice easy target to shoot at but I think
which one of us has to stay in the area
and the signal area and right and
they're right yeah yeah yeah so we're
waiting they go here we go
oh yeah yeah yeah all right I'll stay
here as well yes let's cover that's
covered
take that yeah just let him come to us
alright we've done it I'll find the
other one still love guys but I think by
getting that signal cleared we've
stopped them spawning say nice one yeah
all right boys hey you go good job good
job good job
all right so where to next all right
follow me
Oh en 1000 were heating yeah yeah lay
off that boost we need to find some
waterfalls to fly through over here hmm
I think if you fly through a waterfall
not only does it call your seat down but
it's your next Renata like buff before
you start overheating again that is
surprisingly fun can we try to hit a
bird all right what are you doing Oh God
dinosaurs
wait wait wait I'm overheated oh all
right did you need something else
happening though ah there's a wyvern a
wyvern loaded there we go we've done
good good have I if I just shot forwards
or am I gonna catch up with you guys I
think so you're in the lead okay oh you
know what's happening don't worry I've
got this we will have fun on our tippy I
mean I would say we're still learning to
be a team yeah
getting better at it not the best at it
but I'm a these guys seem relatively big
by comparison to the other things that
we kill before coming we're coming we're
coming this might kill us oh we got this
alright if anyone's got an ultimate now
might be the time easy there already you
said Harry yeah I got it I got it whoo
okay alright that wasn't too bad
yeah we're getting it done
Oh whoo there's an elite dominance storm
okay yep yep um he and I are hanging out
together face-to-face is he nice oh okay
we might actually need to start using a
little bit of strategy here yeah I'm
gonna leave this guy alone I'm gonna
come help you guys I think they're
getting bit Oh Oh what's this there's a
huge there we go ah s team nicely done
okay good nice yeah all right that was
efficient even alone yeah this is also
the first like the first mission I'm
gonna cross yeah also the fact that
playing an easy and feeling like
badasses know but up next hey it's fine
you take this away from me
ya ever push the button yeah ah all
right we gotta go right so everyone stay
in the green zone let's see how well we
can hold this on this spot
oh here they go whoops
I just like to occasionally blow up the
area where in just to keep you guys on
your toes it's kind of a part of a
team-building thing I'm working on
okay
I love this grenade yeah let me sow it's
pretty fun - all right okay let's go you
can mop him up now I like these two back
here
cowards all right we've got one more to
find
or are we all know we can go and get the
manifold now look at this scenic Vista
this map is enormous
like I know we've been sort of dashing
around and shooting wyverns we got small
way back yeah we take care of that that
was not that bad I am also really glad
there's no fall damage kiss yeah oh yeah
we would be dead absolute experts at
pulling the moon is beautiful go I don't
wanna make anyone too nervous but there
is a guy strung up and or on fire here
oh say everything that we can kind of
look forward to and wants to come ah
it's just sleeping he's okay this is
like he's fine okay as we will be Jeanne
I see you are you just getting into
fights on your own
oh you're not there oh sorry okay hey
you wanna watch that those are they will
spit acid at you oh yeah okay we're good
Oh sometimes hurts again plainy buds
flirt flying birds
how about you guys I'm headed towards
that yellow thing yep there's all this
fire coming from is it the wyvern sir
gets the wyverns I feel like these
cabins are gonna really test our
piloting skills ah treasures whoa okay
so this looks like some work yep
okay so have you go in front oh yeah
don't worry boys I got this I think I've
proven oh we got people to kill
come come kill the fools oh and don't
fall down we can get him in one place I
have my old ready all right yeah good
one okay everybody fellas all right the
one gone so one of them sound ot them
down all right if you want to hold that
last one save one for me I'm talking
that I call the river okay well I was
they look tough I didn't do anything
correctly race you to the glowing thing
I mean I see that it is connected it's
contained by a barrier but a genius
you're stood clean through it in my have
we tried throwing flares that I think
wears
flares up I accidentally activated my
alt so that's gone where's all right we
have to go touch several things in the
room okay I'll take the one on the right
I'm doing take the right in front okay
that's glad you wanna get to the one on
the left
max and me will take the one on the left
you slime okay I will take the one on
the left and next would take slime
incorrect you guys good
wait do we need to uh oh should we get
it all the same oh okay so it seems to
be some kind of puzzle so we've got
purple who's the brain and a team okay
okay so let's do this do we have still a
bunny left who can solve this for us
okay so it's all set to purple at the
moment okay let me set in through you
know what all right so uh max yes why
don't you head back over to the barrier
and you tell us when it goes down good
car
pull ring you got it
alright so I presume it's still up from
the moment it is still here alright well
will it purple now let's change to red
is there a blue one cuz the barriers
blue all right let's try Blake okay
let's try blue
there's red let's play okay on blue huh
anything
no it's still still glowing are there
any clues here see is that it's the
secret of this thing this guy is purple
so what what color are you gonna do next
purple let's try alright so just keep
trying stuff and so cool alright say
your skill about the manifold for six
tries yeah we're all in Mensa after that
we're good
I did it guys I see the puzzle yeah I
feel like we did you abandon me I hope
you're the leader I mean you have to do
it well I I must say I feel like you
know even with the same seats even with
us just like getting in on easy mode I'm
I'm feeling like we're we're working as
a better dynamic now exactly the same
experience points so no one feels you
know left out or weird that even though
I went in first every time and sponged
up all that pain for you guys and I
think we should take a quick breather
before we go back in and complete part 2
and part 3 of Mathias is yeah in
restroom break
[Laughter]
oh he's enormous oh we probably should
have saved it one ultimate okay oh yeah
he's you that used to terrain you know
[Music]